hello and thank you for attending my
presentation on combining morphological
and chemical identification for the
interrogation of forensic traces
my name is dr brook camras and i am a
professor
at the university of new haven i'm also
an assistant director at
the henry lee institute of forensic
sciences
this shows an overview of what you'll
hear about today but i'm just going to
get right to it
so what are forensic traces
confusion exists with respect to the use
of the term trace in context of forensic
science investigations
it is used both as a standalone noun and
discussing traces of past events
and as an adjective in the term trace
evidence
when used as a noun it traces a
surviving mark or sign or indication of
the former existence
influence or action of some agent or
event
this sense of the term trace should be
familiar from its use in common
expressions such as vanish without a
trace
or no trace of it could be found when
used as an adjective a trace is a barely
discernible indication of some quantity
or quality such as there's only a trace
of this blue in this way
pigment trace material analysis and
analytical chemistry
reflects this usage where the analyte
sought
is present at only very low levels in a
much larger specimen or sample
but forensic samples don't have to be
small and instead using the trace as a
noun is really a much more appropriate
use for its use in forensic science
now as i said traces are really remnants
of physical
activities and like it's what's shown in
this
image here important traces for an
investigation are typically present in
environments that are seldom pristine
traces of interest for an investigation
need to be recognized separately
from pre-existing ones and those that
were produced during post-event
activities
this is an exceedingly difficult task
which is commonly known as recognition
that has to be curated through education
training and experience
in forensic cases traces can really be
anything you see around you
from fingerprints and blood traces to
glass paint
fibers and the criminalist job
is to analyze these wide variety of
traces
we have a lot of tools available for the
analysis of traces
and today i'm going to be talking about
three new methods for trace evidence
analysis
some of this has been published in
forensic science international
specifically
on the morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy of spiritual analysis
and in an article in spectroscopy on a
variety of other traces
so what are these methods so
particle-driven raman spectroscopy
um it comes in really two forms there's
morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy or mdrs
and pcrs which is particle correlated
raman spectroscopy
now there are some differences between
the two um but ultimately
they both combine automated particle
imaging and raman spectroscopy
where the imaging gives us the particle
size shape
and particle size distributions of the
sample and the raman spectroscopy is
able to give us the chemical
identification
now this is usually paired with some
manner of automated sample preparation
and then the images are the particles
are imaged
followed by the raman spectral analysis
so this shows the workflow for
morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy
first the sample is prepared
and then dispersed onto a glass plate
or slide or a quartz plate or slide
um then you choose your imaging and
raman parameters
and collect images of the particles
followed by
targeting the specific some specific
particle um
characteristics um for raman analysis
so you can use the characteristics to
direct which particles get
get analyzed with the varmint
spectroscopy
and last there'd be data analysis
with particle correlated raman
spectroscopy
the workflow is incr it's very similar
now with morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy
uh the sample preparation is attached to
the instrument
and it's all in one one unit with pcrs
we have a separate particle disperser
which um you then disperse your sample
onto
again a glass or quartz slide or other
other
uninterfering substrate um the
you automatically detect the particles
with the image analysis software
and that provides the particle
information and then again you can
target specific particles for raman
analysis
and then do a data analysis in terms of
multivariate statistics or spectral
matching
with a library and
so this shows the chemical
identification
using raman spectroscopy of a mixture of
soil minerals
with particle correlated raman
spectroscopy
you can see here how uh the software
automatically color
codes the different particles based on
the raman spectral
identification and you can really get
great information
on a variety of different features not
only of the bulk material but
of its distribution among the different
components so this shows the particle
area
as separated by chemical identification
in the minerals
so the black graph shows the part the
full
bulk analysis so all of the particles
area's
distribution whereas the colored graphs
show each of the individual minerals
their specific particle areas
area distributions and this is really
interesting for
providing more information about each
individual chemical
of the mix than really could have been
gotten by a bulk analysis method
and we can do a similar thing with
particle circularity
elongation particle ellipse ratio
and really a number of other
morphological features
so let's show some examples of where
we've used this now this research was
done with morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy
um but we chose to look at a variety of
different
challenging mixtures in forensic science
so
we started with hope uh the hoax powder
pro problem
now in the wake of the september 11th
terrorist attacks there was an influx of
white powder events
both real and hoax throughout the united
states
the most infamous of these white powder
events was the amerithrax attacks in the
fall of 2001
that left 17 people sick and five dead
from anthrax sent via anonymous letters
containing white powders since these
attacks the fbi and u.s postal service
has
responded to thousands of white powder
events more often than not the attacks
do not contain any toxic material
and are carried out for the sole purpose
of causing terror and damaging
infrastructure
these fake bioterrorist agents consist
of white powders
that can come from a variety of uh
different commercial sources
and household products and they may be
blended to further complicate analysis
and they really do happen all the time
and have a variety of targets
they also don't often occur in isolation
as a perpetrator may send letters over a
long period of time
such as in this case where a texas man
sent over 500 white powder letters over
a period of six years
and the targets can range from
politicians to the news media
but we know that nobody really cares
unless it affects celebrities and that
they are targeted as well
so the research we did uh we we looked
at uh
three very commonly available artificial
sweeteners
which to protect proprietary information
they're called
the pink stuff the yellow stuff and the
blue stuff but i think you know what i'm
i'm speaking about
and all of these artificial sweeteners
contain a very small
or trace amount of a sweetening agent
um in the case of the pink stuff at
saccharin the yellow stuff it's
sucralose and the blue stuff uses
aspartame
and then they have a bulking agent which
is the dextrose um in all all three of
them
and this usually um can consist of
or takes up anywhere from 95 to 99
of the whole sample therefore when you
try to analyze these with a bulk
analysis
you're only going to get the dextrose
it's almost impossible to see the
um the sweetening agent
because of just the sheer quantity of
the dextro
so here's um some of the data we have
and uh this shows
that the sweeping agents all are very
different rom and spectra which allow
them to be differentiated very trivially
using this method and this analysis
i had a one second acquisition time and
you can really see the quality of the
raman spectra here
now we need to find those particles
though
from the dextrose and what this shows
is the overall particle size
distribution of the blend so showing
uh all the components within each of the
mixtures and you can see that they're
very similar
um and so uh differentiating these
samples
difficult if not impossible
and when you look at the bulking agent
again
it's the same thing because the dextrose
is the majority of the sample
you're really seeing um that's really
the main contributor to the overall
particle size distribution
however when you look at the
just the identified sweetening agent um
you can see that they're now different
so now not only can they be
differentiated um
well not only can they be found these
you know needles in a haystack
and identified by their ramen spectra
but their particle size distributions
are also very different
and so this really can help um this
method can
really help identify and differentiate
the different artificial sweeteners
from each other in an automated method
now at two artificial sweeteners with
the same ingredients so they both
contain sucralose and dextrose
but one is the name brand and the other
is a generic
and we were wondering if you could tell
the difference um between them using
morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy
so here again shows just the nutritive
dextrose and the distributions of
of their particle sizes are the same
so you wouldn't be able to tell these
apart either by their particle sizes
or their distributions or their chemical
identification
however when you look at the sweetening
agent you can see that the particle size
distributions are very different
so this is a case where the chemistry
isn't going to tell them apart
however their particle size and
morphologies are very different
and so you would be able to
differentiate the generic from the name
brand
using this method
now another problem we tackled was
looking at
both illicit and counterfeit drugs uh
the world
uh drug report by the united nations
estimated
that about 269 million people or
505.3 percent of the world's population
have used a drug
at least once in 2018. and drug use
continues to be on the rise
now it's not just the common drugs like
marijuana and cocaine we're now seeing
designer drugs such as bath salts and
the
opioid epidemic and it's really a huge
problem that just continues to grow
we also have a problem with counterfeit
drugs um and the sale
of counterfeit drugs is estimated to
reach
um over uh 1.2 trillion dollars per year
as of 2018 as well and this has to do
with the growing availability of the
illegal pharmacies online
and morphologically directed ramen
spectroscopy was used
to identify the components of these drug
mixtures
and more than just that it's also able
to potentially provide comparative
source attribution
so the first thing we did was we made a
mixture of
equal parts by weight of five different
common drugs and
this was a very easy problem for mdrs to
identify all components and give us both
the
morphological information about each
component
and the size distributions and particle
size distributions
so mixtures are not a challenge at all
for the sam uh this instrument
we also looked at bath salts now bath
salts are designer drugs of abuse that
used to be available legally you could
buy them in a
gas station or bodega they're now
illegal and they are generally central
nervous
system stimulants and can lead to a
variety of serious and potentially
lethal reactions
in bath salts is mdpv although there are
many other stimulants that might be
present
so this is one example that i purchased
through a website and
it came back with a three competition
mixture
the first component that was identified
with l-dopa that's
a and it seemed a little strange that
that was
uh present but um it was um the second
component was unidentified
although it uh its structure was similar
to a phenethylamine so it could have
been
a bath salt or a catheter that was not
in our spectral library and then the
third component
identified with caffeine and that's not
uncommon to be found in bath salts since
it is intended to be used as a stimulant
and so um we were able to get
information
on the chemical identity of the mixtures
components as well as their morphology
and particle size distribution which
potentially could be used
um for comparative uh purposes
mdrs can also be used for
over-the-counter drugs
and also then compared to a suspected
counterfeit
when we're talking about
over-the-counter drugs we're dealing
with
highly regulated materials so their
particle size distributions were
incredibly reproducible
and you can expect a counterfeit drug um
wouldn't be made in exactly the same way
wouldn't have the same
quality assurance and so the uh the part
even though it generally might contain
the same ingredients because
um counterfeiters want you to rebuy the
material
um there are substandard qualities that
could be detected
with morphologically directed vomit
electronically
uh identif we um contaminated
a sample of uh dextromor uh
dextromethorphan
uh with baking soda just in a one to one
thousand ratio
um and we were still able to find the
baking soda within
the gxm and that was very exciting to
see how
sensitive this method really is
another thing we looked at was soil
forensic soil analysis is one of my
favorite
topics i think it's incredibly
underutilized evidence
it is one of the most traditional
methods it's been used for
over a hundred years and as han grove
said
dirt on shoes can often tell us more
about where the wearer of those shoes
had last been than toil some inquiries
people collect dirt on their
and people don't often think to clean it
off or even if they do clean it off
it might not be incredibly thorough and
a forensic scientist is able to look at
the soil
and examine it using microscopy and
other methods
um and compare the the soil from a shoe
or a shovel or
a a tire tread and compare it to a
source to see if they could have come
from
the if the sample could have come from
that location
one of the most useful properties of
soil that is used for comparison
is the mineral identification and
although there are more than 2 200
minerals are known in existence there
really
are only about 40 that are commonly
encountered in most soils
so um when it comes to traditional
forensic soil analysis
we've been using particle particle size
distributions and mineral
identifications
uh for a long time because uh and
they've been shown to be very useful
comparative features for soil analysis
and so using either ndrs or pcrs for
this analysis
because it combines the two is really
ideal
so here's some results of of one of the
analysis we did
we looked at soil samples uh that we
collected from
uh four sites along a single road in
connecticut
um the mineral portions were separated
out through
washing and um and sieving to get
a certain particle size fraction the the
90 to 180 micron size fraction and when
we analyzed the soil minerals
um in each of those samples there was a
couple surprises
one is um that we had more than than
four components that we were able to
find
not in great amounts but there were
really small amounts
of certain minerals that ended up being
very useful
and um even though these uh
soil samples were within
a short close proximity to each other
they were all able to be distinguished
um based on the presence or absence of
certain minerals so for example sample
site a
contained um epidote
in a certain quantity that was different
than
than other samples or sample c
had adopted dioxide which wasn't present
in any of the other samples
we did
sorry so we also did a principal
component
analysis on the data you can't have a
forensic science presentation nowadays
without some
multivariate statistical analysis
and we did pca principal component
analysis
and you can really see the the
separation of the four different
locations
was really great
um the last type of evidence we looked
at
with mdrs was gunshot residue
gunshot residue is really one a very
common
type of evidence because it's easily
transferred and gun crimes are very
common especially in the united states
the most widely accepted method for
gunshot residue identification is
scanning electron microscopy equipped
with energy disperses
x-ray spectrometry or sem eds
and this method what makes it so
uh useful is that it combines both the
morphology
of the um gunshot residue particles with
the elemental chemistry so you're
looking
for that spherical ball um
and using edf you're going to identify
the
lead barium and antimony components
now if you find these particles if you
find three or more then
it's a positive identification for
gunshot residue
however there is a a big push in the
forensic science community to find
alternative methods um there are a
number of reasons for this
um one of which is uh because lead-free
ammunition or green ammunition it's
really on the rise
and therefore we wouldn't be able to use
the lead bearing
antimony from the primer to make the
identification
now one of the the tools that's being
heavily investigated is the use of raman
spectroscopy for gsr identification
because this can combine both the
organic
and inorganic components of gut jet
residue for identification
one thing that traditional ramen is
missing though is that morphology
so when the primer um is
uh hit and the uh and
put to through the barrel
the primer is vaporized and then it
condenses
back into the little spherical ball so
that's really what's characteristic
is this molten ball of primer
part primer material and so
morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy would be
potentially able to combine that
morphology information
with the analytical chemistry
and what we did was we um
collected uh four test fires at various
distances
and we were able to get both the
particle size
information and particle morphologies
and identify different components
so this shows the spectra of the
nitrocellulose
that we saw and one of the the trends
that we saw that we
was a little bit unexpected
appeared with the muzzle to target
there there was a relationship where the
larger particles
were seen in the um the closer
test-fired
samples and this really does need to be
investigated more
but it's interesting to think that the
morphology could give us information on
muscle to target distance
so some overall conclusions to
particle-driven raman spectroscopy
methods
are that they're non-destructive
relatively fast they're automated
ways to collect chemical and particle
size information about
a range of samples of forensic interest
and
we used this to analyze a range of
traces
um that and we believe that this has the
potential to
enable criminalists to obtain more
information from forensic evidence
than is currently employed for
investigations and adjudications
so one last um tool
typical photothermal infrared plus raman
spectroscopy
and with this method um
opt-ir is really can be described as a
pump
probe optical spectroscopy technique
where the pump is an infrared laser
which excites the sample
uh commonly a qcl laser and the probe is
either a 532 or 785 nanometer laser
and this is what allows for the
simultaneous infrared and raman
analysis also because this technique
uses a visible or near-infrared laser
probe
submicron spatial resolution is possible
and therefore you can get raman-like
spatial resolution with infrared
spectral information
and last although this is a reflection
technique
the spectra that are obtained are really
like transmission and so the spectra are
clean there's no distortions or
artifacts or interference fringes
and they can be searched in traditional
infrared libraries
so this shows a video of how optical
photothermal infrared works
so this uh and i'm going to take you
right through it
it starts with an infrared light probe
which is a pulse source
being incident on the sample now in the
infrared
the diffraction limit is very large
usually 10 microns or greater
the co-linear visible beam can focus
much narrower
at about 500 nanometer spot size
at the surface of the sample the energy
is absorbed
and you get localized heating and
thermal expansion that changes the
refractive index
and sample deformation which then
changes how the green light is scattered
it then measures the green light
intensity as
we tune the infrared wavelengths of the
probe
and this results in a pure absorbance
infrared spectrum that can be compared
to traditional infrared transmission
so there are some key differentiators of
opt-ir to traditional
ftir microscopy um you get
a sub-micron spatial resolution um
you don't have to make contact with your
sample so
you it it operates in reflection and
there's no dispersive
scattering artifacts we don't need to
use an infrared detector
um so no longer do i have to buy my
liquid nitrogen
um you also because it's a surface
technique we don't need to microtome it
to make
thin sections um it can work on any type
of uh
thick section or thin you also don't
have to worry about the substrate it's
on
it works on glass or any other
transparent substrate
and then the the best part about it is
that it collects both infrared and raman
spectra from the same spot at the same
time
with the same spectral resolution
so i used it to analyze paint evidence
and
paint very common evidence we get it
submitted to forensic labs in the form
of automotive paint architectural paint
spray paint
and also in the case of arteries or
or in the case of forgery for artwork
um and the beauty of paint is that it's
highly complex
and there's a huge variety of it so
there's a tremendous variety of colors
and the colors change year to year uh
trends change so believe it or not in
the 1980s red
was one of the most popular colors
whereas now
white is still the most popular color
and has been for about
uh for more than a decade
and the main components of paint um are
the binders solvents
pigments extenders and additives so it
really is
a very complex mixture and not only is
it
that it's applied on a surface so oem
automotive paints
usually have three or four layers you
can have a primer and a primer surfacer
and then a color coat and then a clear
coat but there
there's variations to this as well so
there's a lot of variations which
provides
for its evidentiary significance
we have um standard methods
for analyzing paint and forensic science
uh specifically astm
1610 which was updated in in 2018
um and it shows a flow chart for
examining the physical and chemical
characteristics of automotive paint
and this continues the flow chart and
one thing that you can see
is that in to identify all three
components the binders the pigments or
the additives
you are able to use vibrational
spectroscopy it's an incredibly valuable
but there are and when we analyze those
um materials using traditional ir and
raman microspectroscopy
we do have some limitations so first is
a limited spatial resolution which i
mentioned before
infrared is usually 10 microns ramen is
less
you can get you know a 1 micron spot
size
but with the infrared spectra only going
to about 10
and we have some layers that are are
less than that
it makes it very difficult if not
impossible to get the infrared spectra
of
a sample that with a layer that's less
than 10 microns
it often requires very complex sample
preparations
um total reflection has become very
popular
um it's one of my favorite techniques to
use but it does require intimate contact
um and then with raman spectroscopy
although it has the spatial resolution
and doesn't require contact
um one of the the issues that uh that's
very
problematic is fluorescence
opti won't correct for that but it's
just something we have to live with
so in this is an example of an
automotive paint that we analyzed
um and you can see how how nice the
infrared spectra are
and how um they were able to be
um so we used an infrared a hyper uh so
it shows an optical image and then the
mirage infrared hyperspectral image
overlaid on top of it
and from this information
on the spectra obtained we were able to
identify
um all of the layers of the paint here
by comparing it
to published literature by scott ryland
and ed suzuki
and so the top coat was an oxaphane
the green mid or color color coat was an
acrylic urethane
and then the primer was an acrylic
urethane
modified with melamine and this shows
the ramen spectra
um now to note that the the color code
gave a really beautiful
ramen spectra that enabled us to
identify the pigment as a blue
thiocelenide pigment
here shows the ramen hyperspectral image
that was collected
um and showing it just the the 5 15 20
peak which is from the blue dial
the halo cyanide pigment and really this
could be used
to compare different uh paints because
you can see the distribution of the
pigments within the color code
this is another sample and in this case
we did a line array
which saves a little bit of time and we
got
similarly fantastic infrared spectra
in a matter of minutes um we also
um did mirage ratio imaging which
um allows us to look at the ratio of
different peaks
and which highlights chemical
differences of the layers within a paint
sample
now one thing that's particularly
interesting to me in this is that
it showed a mixing of certain
chemistries at the boundaries
between the two middle layers now this
is only a two micron region
and it isn't uh seen at every wave
number so it's unknown why this is
happening
uh perhaps they used a wet on wet baking
process or one of the layers wasn't
fully dry prior to applying the second
layer
or even potentially there was a
diffusion over time of some of these
chemical components
now although it's not currently used for
for
foreign comparisons um this mixing
at the boundary layer may prove to be
potentially valuable for discrimination
in comparison
this shows the raman hyperspectral image
and the last
uh thing i wanted to show was we did a
comparison of two
red automotive paints that were
indistinguishable by uh microscopy
and you can see that they're very
similar
in appearance now ramen spectroscopy
didn't help us here
um now although uh both samples did
fluoresce
um they fluoresce differently so um
you know it does tell us that they are
potentially different but there's not a
lot of satisfaction
uh doing a comparison just based on
fluorescence
because we weren't able to to really
make any identifications
so looking at different spots on these
two paints we were able to get really
beautiful infrared spectra
that enabled us to do a comparison
um and we looked at also the single
frequency imaging
and one of the things that we did
was delay four uh ratios
and what i find really fascinating here
is that
the effect pigments in the color code
are you can really see the morphologies
of these so
not only are you able to identify the
components and look at the chemistry
but the morphology of the of the
material and the pigments which
um can be seen visually but now
chemically are being mapped and that's
really amazing in my book
so getting back to the chemistry uh the
opt-ir analysis
uh showed real um you know some subtle
differences between the two
and when we uh did a infrared spectral
interpretation uh although both clear
coats contained acrylic melamine enamel
there were differences in the chemistry
of all the three other coats that
enabled these
uh two red paints um to be
clearly distinct
one another so
in conclusion um so new developments in
instrumentation uh specifically with
morphologically directed raman
spectroscopy particle correlated raman
spectroscopy and optical photothermal
infrared
plus raman spectroscopy will enable more
information to be obtained
from the analysis of complex samples
than could be previously obtained
by morphological or chemical information
alone
so in my book it's really like uh one
plus one equals three here
and these tools can be used for a range
of forensic samples
i have a lot of people i collaborate
with and i'm i'm indebted
to all of them
i'd like to thank university of new
haven for supporting my research
and my collaborators at hariba at
malvern analytical at microtrace at john
jay college
ohio university and last but not least
is
a photo thermal which makes the opt-ir
and if there are any questions please
feel free to to reach out by email
i'm happy to answer any questions anyone
has
and thank you for attending